really don't want to talk to your
lawyers why why did you why did they put
you in jail I mean I know it's Guilty By
Association can they even do that when
digging through Andrew's entire past
trying to find a reason to put him in
jail what you have to understand is
we have not been accused by X number of
women the prosecutor has accused of us
of doing X to X number of women these
women actually defend us actively one of
the statements in the file is a girl who
I used to date a little bit she details
nothing illegal says nothing illegal
went on she wasn't held against her will
she wasn't trafficked she wasn't
exploited but
because I used to sleep with her I guess
I'm guilty too so I mean I guess one of
the girls is my ex so that's the only
real link